The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So who's going lecture?
Good.
Does everything makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Mostly.
PROFESSOR: That's good, because
we're going to do problems.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
PROFESSOR: So, what I want
to talk about is, first,
there's a subtlety in the
Rubik's cube problem, which I'm
guessing nobody has seen yet,
but we're going to talk about
it anyway, because otherwise
you'll trip on it while you're
doing the problem.
And then we're going to
talk about one or maybe two
problems.
And I'm excited about
the problem titled,
"there's StarCraft
and counter strikes,"
so, let's hope we get to them.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious, did you
write this week's problem set?
Because there's some
Chinese in there.
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: No,
someone else wrote it.
I suggested putting
that in there, though.
AUDIENCE: You had an
awesome internship, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Wait, did you make all
the AMD [INAUDIBLE] questions?
PROFESSOR:Of course.
That's my stuff.
OK.
So Rubik's cubes.
Did everyone see a 2
by 2 by 2 Rubik's cube?
You guys are going
to lecture, right?
You have one.
Yeah.
Did you guys see Eric's
2 by 2 by 2 Rubik's cube?
It looks sort of like this.
All right, so big
Rubik's cube has how many
small cubelets in it?
AUDIENCE: 80.
AUDIENCE: I like cubelets
better than cubies.
Cubies is hard to say.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
would say cubicles.
So let's go for--
let's try cubelets
and see how this works.
OK.
So each cubelet has six
faces, but three faces
are always facing inwards.
They're always attached
to the center of the cube.
So we don't care about them.
We only care about
the other three faces.
So if you have a
plastic Rubik's cube.
Say this is a plastic--
This is a plastic cube.
Then you're going to have
eight plastic cubelets.
Each cubelet has
three colored faces
and three faces that
we don't care about.
So how many total plastic
faces in a cubelet, sorry,
plastic cube?
AUDIENCE: Twenty-four.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Now let's play with
an imaginary cube.
And I call this
a wireframe cube,
because I draw it like this.
So, here pretend you have the
skeleton of a Rubik's cube,
made out of wires or out
of wood or something.
So it's basically a small sheet
of wood, small piece of wood,
small sheet of wood,
so on and so forth.
And so this doesn't
have any colors in it,
but it's the right shape
and sort of the right look.
So the way you would build
the configuration is,
you take 24 plastic faces that
you get from a plastic cube,
and you paste them one
by one onto the faces
of a wireframe cube.
And they claim that this
can build any configuration
that you can think about.
If you look at a cube, after
no matter how many moves
you've done to it,
it's going to have
some-- it's going to have
the faces somewhere, right?
So you can take the
faces and face them
where they belong
and there you go.
You have a real cube
built out of a wireframe
and plastic faces.
How many wireframe
faces there are?
Please don't get this wrong.
AUDIENCE: Twenty-four.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: There are
some configurations
that aren't possible, right?
PROFESSOR: OK.
There are some configurations
that aren't possible,
and that is very good news.
We'll get to that later.
Let's see how the code
talks about these faces.
So suppose we have a cubelet
that has these faces.
Front faces yellow, this face is
blue, and this face is orange.
This facing code is called--
so this yellow face here
is called y o b.
So y is yellow, that's
the yellow face,
and is the yellow
facing the cubelet that
has a yellow face, an orange
face, and a blue face.
Fortunately, there
aren't two cubelets
that have the same face
color, so this is good enough
to distinguish
between all of them.
Let's see if you guys
are paying attention.
How would I call this face?
AUDIENCE: o y b?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Either that or o b y, whichever
one the code happens to use.
So the principal is,
these are the colors
and the first one is the
face that you're pointing at.
So there are 24
plastic faces, so there
are 24 names for
these plastic faces.
Let's see how we name
the wireframe faces.
If I take this face-- so
we don't have colors here,
they're all the same.
So instead we care
about their position.
A cube has a front
and a back, right?
This cubelet is on the
front somewhere, right?
So I'm going to have front
somewhere in the name.
It has an upper face
and a lower face.
Is this going to
be upper or lower?
AUDIENCE: Upper.
PROFESSOR: And
the left or right?
PROFESSOR: Right.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So front upper right,
which face am I looking at?
AUDIENCE: The front.
PROFESSOR: OK.
f u r, fur.
How about this space?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So far so good?
Or it could be r u f, right?
PROFESSOR: Or it could be r u f.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I really don't know
what it means, I'm behind.
AUDIENCE: Ruff like a dog?
It has fur.
PROFESSOR: Oh, ruff ruff ruff.
OK.
That's not too bad.
I was afraid of something worse.
OK.
That's cool.
So a configuration
will take plastic faces
and face them onto
the wireframe faces.
So a configuration is going
to be an array of 24 elements.
And the first element is going
to tell me which plastic face
ends up in-- Let's say if
you are the second one,
says which plastic
face ends up in r u f,
and the third one, let's
assume it's the space.
AUDIENCE: Ruff.
PROFESSOR: Ruff.
And there are 21
more faces, right?
So each face has
a number from zero
to 23, because we're in Python,
so we like zero-based indexing.
And 24 elements in the
array, 24 plastic faces.
Which plastic face
goes into f u r?
Assuming this cubelet here--
see, I said cubicle anyway.
This cubelet here goes here
in exactly this configuration.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this face ends up here.
And that's what it means that
the first element in the array
is y o b.
How about r u f?
Who ends up in r u f?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: B o y.
PROFESSOR: And who
ends up in e r f?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So does everyone
understand configurations?
Does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I got lost somewhere in there.
Can you explain the order
for f u r and [INAUDIBLE]?
Like front upright?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
So do you mean-- so the
order of the letters.
So there are two orderings here.
One is the order of the
letters and there is an order.
I think the code
uses clockwise order,
but what really matters is the
first letter tells you which
face you're talking about.
AUDIENCE: So this is front face.
PROFESSOR: Face, up face.
AUDIENCE: What's up?
What's front?
PROFESSOR: So for this
cubelet, this is front,
this is the right, this is up.
This cubelet wold have a
front, an up, and a left.
So now there are
24 faces and all
of them get numbers from 0 23.
And here we assume that
f u r is space zero,
r u f is space 1, and
e r f is face 2, which
is not quite [INAUDIBLE], but
you'll have the mapping there.
OK.
So a configuration is in
an array of 24 elements
and it maps plastic faces
to wireframe faces, which
brings us to, how many
configurations are there?
AUDIENCE: You mean like
mapping 4 factorial?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's see what it does.
We have 24 plastic faces.
From 0 to 23.
And they have to be
mapped to 24 positions.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: There's six
colors, aren't there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: There are six colors,
but if this is also yellow,
but there's a red here.
This is a different face,
see, this is yellow,
red, and there's
a green down here.
Then this is the yellow face of
the yellow, green, red cubelet.
So we care about the
individual faces.
So yeah, your answer was right.
I'm trying to explain
it to everyone else.
But your answer is right.
AUDIENCE: Well, wait.
But you can't-- I mean, we
talk about some are impossible.
Like, you're always gonna
have a grouping of y o b.
That's never gonna change.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So some of these
aren't reachable,
because you're not allowed
to break up the cube.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And that's OK.
This is still how the
code represents them.
So I'm asking if you had-- if
all these would be possible,
how many would we get?
And the answer is that
to map 24 plastic faces
to 24 wireframe faces.
So this mapping is called--
anyone good with math?
AUDIENCE: 1 to 1.
AUDIENCE: Bijection.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So when you're taking-- OK.
So when we have two sets and you
have a bijection between them
or 1 to 1 mapping, that
function is also called?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You probably
don't know the answer yet.
You have to wait
until the end of 6042.
So I'm trying to hint that
right now, if you remember
the end of 6042, maybe the
answer is somewhere there.
AUDIENCE: Blur?.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
AUDIENCE: A perfect match
AUDIENCE: Permut--.
AUDIENCE: I totally learned
about that in middle school,
I think.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is--
AUDIENCE: Permutations
and combinations.
PROFESSOR: So this
is a permutation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: How many permutations
do you have out of 24 elements?
AUDIENCE: Does that order
[? mean ?] [? matters ?]
[INAUDIBLE] 24 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this is a
lot of permutations, right?
It's a good thing
that we're not going
to explore most of
these configurations.
So we said before,
that we're going
to build a graph where the
vertices are configurations,
and the edges are
moves that get us
from one configuration
to another configuration.
Can they afford to build
this graph first and then run
BFS on it?
Not going to work, right?
We don't have
enough RAM for this.
So instead we're going
to have to operate
on an implicit graph
for presentation.
Well, fortunately, BFS
doesn't want the whole graph.
The way BFS works is
it has a list of nodes
that it has to visit, and
when it visits a node,
it wants to know its neighbors.
And that's it.
Yes?
Everyone happy with it?
So all they have
to do is, in order
to build this implicit
graph representation,
is we have to know
the start node,
So BFS can start somewhere.
And we have to be able
to give it a node,
we have to be able to generate
all the neighbor nodes.
So given the
configuration, we have
to be able to generate
the configurations that
would result by applying
most of that configuration.
So what are the moves
that you can do with this?
Suppose you have a cubelet.
What are the possible moves?
There aren't that many.
We're interested in the
simplest kind of moves.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you
can make the right side
go right, which is equivalent
to the left side going left.
And then you can do [INAUDIBLE]
4, left [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It's a nice number.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I think there are a few more,
so here's how I look at it.
You can take the front
face, so these four,
and do a clockwise
rotation, 90 degrees,
or you can do a counterclockwise
rotation, 90 degrees.
And you can do
that for each face.
AUDIENCE: But doing a front
clockwise rotation is the same
as doing a back counter
clockwise rotation, which
is [? it-- ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Doing
a front clockwise,
doing a back counterclockwise
is the same thing
after you account
for symmetries.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So it's six?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So there's only six after
you account for symmetries.
Let's play devil's
advocate and assume
we don't account for symmetries.
We're actually doing
the code, because I
need to teach you something.
So let's assume we don't apply.
By the way, how
would you account
for symmetries, easy way?
Did anyone read the
comments in the code?
OK.
So would you account
for symmetries.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
it just happen?
The permutation is
going to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Can you
just look at it,
like, each space is neighboring
faces, and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So the way we do
it is we anchor one cubelet.
So we have one cubelet that
is a plastic cubelet that
is always going to go here.
So three plastic
faces here are always
going to go to three
wireframed faces here.
And if you fix those
three faces then
you don't have simple
symmetries anymore.
All right?
Three axes of symmetry, so
fixing three faces settles it.
AUDIENCE: Wait, so then how
many moves are possible?
12?
AUDIENCE: No.
But you only do
one thing, though.
Now you don't do
counterclock-- you don't do.
AUDIENCE: If one is
anchored, there's six left.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
You don't move the anchored one.
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah, because
you can only [INAUDIBLE] two
of the-- three of
the faces now, but.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's look at the left face.
So you have a configuration.
So you can move the
left face clockwise,
left face counterclockwise.
You can move the top
face clockwise, top face
counterclockwise,
and a couple more.
So what does a move look like?
Someone said it before.
So when you're doing a move,
what's going to happen is,
a move doesn't
create plastic faces
and it doesn't
destroy them, right?
It just changes their
position on the wireframe.
So if you have an initial
configuration that
has plastic faces assigned
to wireframe faces,
and you have a
final configuration,
these plastic faces are
going to end up somewhere
on the wireframe.
And that's true for
all the plastic faces.
So the plastic faces are
going to end up somewhere.
Also, what's nice is if
we look at the wireframe,
if I do a clockwise rotation
in the front, whatever
plastic face was here
is going to end up here.
Whatever plastic face was
here is going to end up here,
so on and so forth.
So it's a function of rotation
[INAUDIBLE] inside [INAUDIBLE].
Like the four faces that
correspond to each other,
rotate.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's some good-- that's
going deeper than want to go.
I want to account for
something simpler.
So my point is that
the arrows will always,
if I do a right
clockwise rotation,
the arrows will
always look the same.
So the only thing that changes
is what's inside the array.
But if you take one
configuration array
and you move things
according to the way you're
supposed to move them for
the front clockwise move,
you're going to get
the right result.
So what is this a
bunch of arrows called?
What does it do?
What does it do to the faces?
What does it do to the
elements of the array?
AUDIENCE: It moves
in different spots.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
fancy math name?
AUDIENCE: Shuffle.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is what I got before.
This is how you
think of it, right?
It's a shuffle, so fancy
math name for a shuttle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
AUDIENCE: Something
going on here.
PROFESSOR: So then a move is a?
AUDIENCE: Rotation
[? permutation?].
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, so the
thing is-- the difficult part
of the code is you
have two things that
are represented by permutations.
Configurations are
permutations of plastic faces
onto the array, onto the
array of wireframes faces.
And then a move is a
permutation of a configuration
into another configuration.
OK, so now if I want
to compute neighbors,
I take-- we think
there are six moves,
so I'm going to take six moves.
I'm going to type out the
permutations, so 6 times
24 numbers, and that's it.
Now I can compute neighbors.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: I think you
have all the permutations.
PROFESSOR: So there
are six moves, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
then it's right.
Oh yeah--
PROFESSOR: If I take
a configuration,
and I apply the
permutation for this move,
I'm going to get a
new configuration,
and that's its neighbor.
So if I apply the
permutation for LC 4,
left clockwise to
this configuration,
I get the new configuration.
So all I need to do is hard
code those configurations,
and then I'm done.
I can compute neighbors.
But that's a lot of typing.
I don't want to type as much.
I want to reduce my
burden a little bit.
And we can do that by noticing
that some moves are associated
with some other moves.
So, if I go left
clockwise move, that's
the inverse of a left
counterclockwise move.
So, if given the permutation,
I could compute its inverse,
then I wouldn't have to
type as many permutations.
Right?
Why do I care about that?
Did anyone take 6004?
Remember?
So at some lab, which
is the dreaded beta lab,
you have to write the control
block for a processor, right?
And that's a lot of zeros and
1's that you have to type.
And if you get one wrong,
good luck to [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: 18 wide and 64 tall.
PROFESSOR: I know.
AUDIENCE: Copy and paste like.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and copy paste.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Bad memory.
Let's move on.
So two good news, two
pieces of good news.
One, some of these are
redundant in our case, two,
we wrote everything for you, so
you don't have to write them,
we're just teaching
you how we did them,
because the inverse of
a permutation is cool
and I think it's a
good concept to know.
So let's look at how
a permutation looks
like and compute its
inverse and then move on
to other nice problems.
OK so let's take a
presentation of five elements,
not going to go to
24 on the board here.
3, 5, 1, 2, 4.
This is how permutations
look like in math mode.
If you want to be
more explicit, you
can add a row numbers above.
And this is a bit more explicit
about what a permutation does.
So permutation takes an input
list, let's say a b c d e.
And for this is an output list,
according to the recipe that
you see here .
So this pretty much says, the
first element of the output
is the third element
of the input.
The second element of the
output is the fifth element
in the input.
Wait, this is the
wrong permutation.
It doesn't look as pretty, so
I'm changing the permutation.
The third element of the
output is the first element
in the input.
The fourth element of the
output is which letter?
So which letter?
AUDIENCE: Oh. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And the fifth element
of the output is which letter?
AUDIENCE: Did you mean
to get c instead of a?
No.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That would make more
sense, wouldn't it?
Thank you.
OK.
So if this is
permutation pi, then this
is the effect of applying
pi to this original list.
Now the inverse of a
permutation by minus 1
is another bunch of arrows,
and what I want to do
is, if I take this, which
is the output of pi,
and I run it through
these arrows,
I want to get back a b c d e.
So I want to undo
the effect of pi.
OK.
How do I compute this inverse?
How do I compute pi
minus 1 given pi?
AUDIENCE: Wait, you're
giving us the initial,
when we start with c d a e b?
PROFESSOR: You only
start with this.
This doesn't matter at all.
A different list would
get different results.
So this is the permutation,
and I want pi to the minus 1.
AUDIENCE: So you take the value.
So you have 3 4 1 5 2.
So the value at index
1 you put that index,
that index has a value
of index 3, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: So c would
go to position 1?
AUDIENCE: Wait.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Is it true
that you can run pi,
so the number of times it will
eventually equal pi inverse?
PROFESSOR: Yes, but
that's complicated algebra
to prove that.
AUDIENCE: Not forget that.
Just like make that
[INAUDIBLE] thing that you made
and sort of flip it.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I like that.
So 34152, 1 2 3 4 5.
Except this doesn't
look very pretty,
so I need to sort
them again, right?
So 1 3, 2 5, 3 1, 4 2, 5 4.
Right?
Did you guys come
up with it now?
Congrats.
So this is good.
This is how you
compute an inverse.
Let's figure out why you
compute an inverse that way.
Let's look at b.
So b starts out at
position 2, right?
And then pi of 5 equals 2, which
means that, after applying 5,
b is going to go to position 5.
So pi inverse has to
take b and put it where?
Back to 2, right?
Otherwise it's not
a good inverse.
So pi inverse of 2.
So the second
element in the output
has to be which
element in the input?
5, right?
Otherwise, this wouldn't
undo the effect of pi.
So if you write out our
permutation and split
the index and the value, we
get the inverse permutation.
So you can compute that with a
couple of lines of Python code.
OK.
So this lets us now compute
some of the permutations there.
So we only have to type
up two, three, four,
or something like that.
It's a bit nicer
and you guys don't
have to type up any,
because we gave them to you.
Aren't we nice?
All right.
Any questions about
permutations or Rubik's cubes?
AUDIENCE: Wait, so
to get high inverse
based off those numbers,
you just-- well,
it's the same thing.
Wait, but 5 got flipped.
Or you think the maybe if the
inverse of that matrix then?
PROFESSOR: So you take these
two and you flip them, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And then you keep
these bound, but you sort them.
2 5, 3 1, 4, no-- 3 5 1 2 4.
AUDIENCE: Oh they're still
based off the top row?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: Wait, how did
he get the second one?
AUDIENCE: Based off the top row.
PROFESSOR: So you sort this
one, but you keep the bonds,
so 3 ends up here and it
gives it 1, 4 ends up here
and it gives us 2.
OK.
So this make sense?
Good.
We're remembering
that, that's good.
Now let's talk about a problem.
So this is a Rubik's cube,
this is how it works.
Hopefully we will remember
how to solve game.
Let's try to solve
StarCraft Well,
of course we're going to cheat.
We're going to solve a
simpler version of StarCraft
because it turns out you
can't really solve StarCraft
with the computers
that we have now.
So let's make a few
simplifying assumptions.
Who play StarCraft, by the way?
Two?
OK.
So you guys, please
pay attention
to the simplifying
assumptions, because this
isn't real StarCraft.
It's a lot easier, so that we
can build a problem out of it.
All right.
So we're going to play
with a race called Zerg.
And so the idea of StarCraft
is you build an army
and then you take
this army and you
destroy your opponent,
nice and simple.
Good old violent games.
So we're going to look at the
build order part of the game.
So the build order is the
opening strategy and it takes
care of the building process,
so it's the strategy that says,
what are you going
to build and when,
in order to come up with an
army as quickly as possible?
So the main goal is to amass
an army quickly and then take
that army and
destroy the opponent.
And yes, I know, not
real life StarCraft,
but let's go with it.
OK, so these are the
rules in our toy StarCraft
And the Zerg is started with a
building called the hatchery.
And out of a hatchery--
the currency of the game,
by the way, is minerals.
We'll write that
down as dollars.
So out of a hatchery
you can build a drone
by spending 50 minerals.
You can build an
overlord by spending 100,
or you can build a
Zergling by spending 50.
All right, what do
each of these do?
A drone harvests minerals
for you, so it's a worker.
So, for every drone
that you have,
you get eight minerals a second.
So drone gets you eight
minerals a second.
As Zergling is your
attack unit, so this
is the guy that you want
to build in the end.
So this destroys your opponents.
I don't know how to make a
nice icon for that, so big
smiley green.
This makes it happy.
All right.
Overlords help you
control your units,
so drones and
Zerglings are units.
You can't build-- for every
eight units that you build,
you have to have an overlord.
Otherwise, you can't
build more units
until you build overlords.
So if you have eight drones,
you can't build a ninth on one
you build an overlord.
If you have eight drones
and these eight Zerglings,
you have to build
a second overlord
to be able to build more units.
So one overlord can help
you control eight units.
In order to build
a Zergling, which
is what you want
to do in the end,
because these are the attack
units, you need to spend $50,
and you also need to
have one building called
a spawning pool.
You what?
All right.
So how do you build
that spawning pool?
Drones can work for
you, but they can also
transform into buildings.
So a drone mutates into a
building, and after it mutates,
it doesn't work for you
anymore, by the way, so no more
minerals.
So a drone can mutate into the
spawning pool for 200 minerals,
I think.
It can mutate into a hatchery.
That's the same thing
that you have up here for,
how much is it?
$450.
And it can mutate into
an evolution chamber
that we'll talk
about soon, for $400.
OK.
Why do we care about having
more than one hatchery?
One hatchery can build one unit
per second, no more than that.
So once you have a lot
of drones and you're
making a lot of money, you need
to have a lot of hatcheries
so that you can spend the money.
Our goal is not to amass money,
it's to build units, right?
So money doesn't
help you, I'm going
to spend it as fast as possible.
OK.
An evolution chamber
lets you build-- let's
you upgrade research
to technologies.
And these technologies
aren't like badges.
Once you get them,
you keep them.
So you can research
an attack upgrade
and you can research
a defense upgrade.
They're both 1,000 minerals,
but you only have to do it once.
Why do I care about these?
They decide how strong
your Zerglings are.
So, given a Zergling, at
the beginning of the game,
you don't have the
attack upgrade,
and you don't have
a defense upgrade.
So the Zerglings attack is 1.
If you research
the attack upgrade,
but you haven't researched
the defense one,
their total power is 133.
If you research the defense
upgrade, but not the attack
upgrade, their
total power is 1.2.
And after your research both of
them, their total power is 2.
Again, oversimplifying.
So, we have to build an army
that's as powerful as possible.
So in the end you want to
have both of these researched.
All right.
Now there's one more
limitation, that is,
you cannot control more than
200 of these units total,
because even if you
have a lot of overlords,
your brain isn't immensely huge,
so you can only control 200
units.
So we want to build these 200
units as fast as possible.
And out of these
200 units, we want
to have at least 150 Zerglings.
If you build 200
drones, you're not
going to attack your
opponent with that,
those aren't very useful.
But you need some drones
in order to make money,
so you need the balance.
So the goal is to get to 200
units as quickly as possible,
and at least 150 Zergs.
Yes?
Evolution chamber.
Easy, that's too much.
OK.
So how do we solve this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So how
do we solve this?
AUDIENCE: Watch the pros play.
PROFESSOR: Well, they're going
to play real StarCraft this
is toy StarCraft this is
six-level 6 StarCraft so it's
not going to work.
But there is a simple
strategy, because I
haven't added one
last constraint.
AUDIENCE: Lets me guess.
PROFESSOR: No.
It's going to be
harassing your enemy.
But if you don't have to
harass your enemy intuitively
and build your economy
first, so first
build your drones
and hatcheries,
and then pop out
Zerglings, right?
So there's a greedy strategy.
If you spend about an hour
with a sheet of paper,
you can realize what
is the right order
to build drones and
hatcheries and overlords,
so that you get to a nice
big economy, and then, Bam!
Build Zerglings.
Once you get to 50 drones,
you start build Zerglings
as fast as possible.
So this is a greedy
strategy, you
don't need to do a
lot of work for that.
So we want to make
things more interesting.
So in order to make
things more interesting,
the game time goes in seconds.
Everything that we had
here is in seconds.
Every two minutes, so two
minutes, which is 120 seconds.
So every two minutes
I want to assemble
a small pack of
Zerglings and send them
to the enemy to harass them.
And the Antonio enemy
will defend themselves
and they will
destroy my Zerglings,
but they won't be able to
focus on the game very well.
So I need to do this in order
to have a good chance to win.
If I don't do this, my
strategy is invalid.
AUDIENCE: Does the enemy,
does it do that to us as well?
PROFESSOR: No.
We're sending them facts.
We are going to have a really
fast strategy, because we're
computing the optimal
strategy, so they're not
going to have time.
They're going to
be fighting us off.
OK, how many
Zerglings do I send?
I have to send enough
Zerglings so that the attack
power at minutes 2m is
6 times log 1 plus m.
You knew there has to
be some mapping there.
So the reason for this is, let's
look at the first two minutes.
After two minutes, if we
haven't researched any upgrades,
we need to send this
in six Zerglings.
If we researched both
upgrades, we only
need to send in three Zerglings.
If we researched
one of the upgrades,
we need to send
in five Zerglings.
So this is the
total attack power,
not the numbers are of
Zerglings that we need to send.
AUDIENCE: And is minutes?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
it's basically
which attack wave you're
doing, so every two minutes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
So the first one
is m equals zero.
PROFESSOR: And 1.
That is not the one attacking
right in the beginning
when we don't have Zerglings.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Equals 1, n equals 2,
n equals 3, so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: How did
you get that formula?
OK.
PROFESSOR: Is it
making your life hard?
Would that be logged base
2, or is that log base 10?
PROFESSOR: Sure, log base 2.
Fine.
OK, so how are we
going to solve this?
Intuitively, how did
we solve all the game
problems, all the
problems recently?
What are we going to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the
first thing we're
going to build a graph, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So build a graph.
The vertices are the
states of the game,
so a vertex shows
me what state I'm in
and an edge shows
possible moves that I do.
So what I need to keep track
in the vertex, what's my state?
AUDIENCE: How much money
you have, and how many units
you have?
And maybe how fast
you're making money?
AUDIENCE: Oh, unless
the states, are
states-- they're not movable?
Oh, I guess they could be
moveable [INAUDIBLE] could
do nothing, in the
next second, right?
PROFESSOR: So you're saying
you need to keep track of time,
too?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
PROFESSOR: OK so maybe time.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Badge
[INAUDIBLE] thing.
PROFESSOR: OK so upgrades.
You said units, I'm
going to say buildings.
AUDIENCE: Wait, is
Zergling is a building?
PROFESSOR: A Zergling
is a unit, so-
AUDIENCE: Overlords.
PROFESSOR: Unit, unit, unit.
Building, building,
building, upgrade, upgrade.
So let's see how are we
going to keep track of them.
That's a good point.
We started looking at units,
we started looking at units.
So how do I keep
track of my units?
What I need to know?
AUDIENCE: The number of
drones, overlords, servlings.
PROFESSOR: Droids, drones,
overlords, Zerglings.
OK.
How about buildings?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] PHEC--
PROFESSOR: Almost.
So I want to know the
number of hatcheries,
because this is how
fast I can produce.
But then how many spawning
pools am I going to build?
Good.
So that was StarCraft player 1.
Once you have a spawning
pool, you can build Zerglings,
there's no reason to
build more than one.
So a spawning pool is
going to be like a badge.
Once you build it, you
have it, you're done.
So it's Boolean.
AUDIENCE: Wait, what's
a spawning pool again?
PROFESSOR: So a spawning
pool is something
that you build off a drone
and once you have it,
you can build Zerglings
from a hatchery.
So that's all it does.
AUDIENCE: Why would
you want two if you
can build four Zerglings?
PROFESSOR: So the spawning
pool doesn't build a Zergling.
See, the hatchery
builds the Zerglings.
So the spawning
pool is just there.
You need to have it
to cross the edge.
Otherwise you can't.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I understand.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what else for buildings?
Whether you have
it or not, right?
OK.
How about upgrades?
[INAUDIBLE] a u, d u.
PROFESSOR: So two
flags, a u, d u.
Cool.
So now we have the thorny
issues of money and time.
Let's say that we're going to
have some sort of approximation
that's going to allow us
to not keep track of money,
because money is-- you
can have a lot of money,
so that will give us
an explosion of states.
So we're going to assume
that we're spending money
as fast as possible,
because that's
what you usually want to do.
AUDIENCE: So should your
money always be zero then?
PROFESSOR: Almost.
It's very close to that.
So you start off with no money.
You accumulate
money, then you're
going to issue some build
orders and build something.
And your money's
going to drop, maybe
to zero, maybe to almost zero.
Then you wait to
accumulate more money,
issue another build order.
Wait to accumulate more money,
hopefully it goes faster now.
Issue another build order.
We're going to approximate
that every time we
issue a build order,
so every time we
tell our things to
build something,
the money will drop to zero.
So that doesn't mean you
can only build one thing
and then your money
drops to zero.
If you wait for a few
seconds and then you
have two hatcheries and tell
both of them to build drones,
you build two drones and
then your money goes to zero.
So that means that if we
model our states carefully,
we don't have to
keep track of money.
AUDIENCE: You should
probably keep track of time.
AUDIENCE: Actually
keep track of the rate
you're gathering though, right?
PROFESSOR: So what's the
rate that you're gathering?
AUDIENCE: It's the number of--
AUDIENCE: Oh [INAUDIBLE]
drones, yeah. [INAUDIBLE], OK.
PROFESSOR: So this
multiplied by 8%.
AUDIENCE: So we should
keep track of time.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how would we solve it
if we keep track of time?
AUDIENCE: You multiply
AUDIENCE: Can you do
that layer thing again?
Where is that?
PROFESSOR: So you're going
to have-- so what's a layer?
AUDIENCE: Actually, never mind.
AUDIENCE: I want to
know what a layer is.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I want to
know what a layer is.
PROFESSOR: So last time we-- we
solved problems by saying that,
so we had the graph of streets.
We had a highway graph.
And that was a 2D graph.
And we made it into a
3D graph by adding time
as a third dimension.
So we had layers,
where each layer was,
said that you're at
a point in the graph
at a certain point in time.
So there's a layer 4
times 0, layer 4 time 1,
so on and so forth.
And you start at time 0 and
kept going up the graph.
AUDIENCE: You have
a flag that says,
I've just purchased something?
Because that way then you'll
know that you've completely
exhausted your-- that
maybe that will tell you
that you can't buy
anything for awhile, right?
Because if we're not
keeping track of money then
we should know [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that's a good point.
So if I have-- so suppose here
I have to wait for five seconds
to get enough
money to do a move.
If I keep track of
time in my state and I
have five things here.
I also have to keep
track of money, right?
I have to know how
much money I'm getting,
so that I know where
I'm buying things.
On the other hand,
in this case, if I
keep track of both time
and money as states,
I can implement a
precise strategy.
I don't need this approximation.
If I do that, then what
search algorithm would I use?
So if I have time in states,
so each vertex in my note
says that I get from some
states to some other state
in one unit of time.
What algorithm do I use
to search for my strategy?
Yeah.
Why do I use BFS?
AUDIENCE: Because every
edge has the same weight.
PROFESSOR: Every edge has
the same weight, right?
So if we keep
track of time, then
we-- we keep track of time,
we keep track of money,
we use BFS, we have a solution.
So.
Let's try to not do
it, either of these.
If I don't want to
keep track of time
and I don't want to
keep track of money,
what would an edge be?
If I want to say that, hey, this
is a state and this is a state.
What should be the
edge connecting them.
AUDIENCE: What other
item you got is.
AUDIENCE: Is that
after a second?
PROFESSOR: So the
distance between these
won't be a second, right?
If I have to wait
for five seconds to
accumulate enough to
issue this build order
that would get me
the state then--
AUDIENCE: The time
you have to wait?
PROFESSOR: So that's what
I would put on an edge.
So this way I don't have
to keep track of money,
I don't have to
keep track of time.
So the graph is smaller.
So I can look into
bigger graphs.
If I do this, what
algorithm do I use?
To find my strategy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: So no time, no money.
And [? extra ?].
So this looks
reasonably easy, right?
I mean, if you want to get
from one state to another,
you see what you'd
have to build,
you see how much
it costs, and you
see how much you have to wait
to accumulate those resources.
Except there's one glitch.
How do we deal with this?
How do we make sure that we do
our attacks on time and how do
we know that we're-- how
do we keep track of them?
AUDIENCE: What is this
again representing?
PROFESSOR: So this is
that every two minutes you
have to have a
number of Zerglings
that you're sending
to attack the enemy.
And the number of Zerglings
that you need to have
depends on the time and
it depends on the upgrades
that you got.
So how do we keep track of this?
AUDIENCE: If the edges
are a function of time,
then just know that at radius
120-- at radius 120 over 5,
then you'd have to
send more Zerglings.
PROFESSOR: So what if not all
the edges have the same weight.
So let's look at how a graph
looks like for a little bit.
So we're going to
have an initial state,
say one hatchery and six
drones and one overlord.
And we want to
build a new drone.
Say we want to
A drone costs 50 minerals.
We have six drones.
Each drone gets us
eight minerals a second,
so in one second we're
going to get 48 minerals.
So bummer, we have to wait for
two seconds to build one drone.
And now we're going to be in
the state of one hatchery, seven
drones, one overlord.
If you said we want to
build a hatchery-- then
we're going to need to
accumulate 400 or 450.
Oh, we have to accumulate 450,
using six drones, 48 minerals,
so I guess nine seconds.
So we're going to have
to wait for nine seconds
to get that money.
And then when we
build, we're going
to spend the drone
building, because it's
going to turn into a hatchery.
And then we're going to end
up with two hatcheries, five
drones, and one overlord.
So edges have different weights.
So I can't look at the radius
in terms of number of his edges.
AUDIENCE: Everything
builds instantaneously.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: You could keep track
of just the total distance
from whatever starting
build you are?
AUDIENCE: Actually,
if the distance
from the origin to where
you're at is a multiple of 120,
then you should
have another state
that you have to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Assuming you have any
drones left, hopefully you do.
PROFESSOR: So that's modeling.
One way of doing it is
sure, model every round
of the attack as one,
every round of harassment
is one there in the graph,
and we can do it that way.
Is that what you're saying?
So you can't-- once
you're at 120 seconds,
you have to do an attack and
then you get to the next layer
in the graph.
AUDIENCE: That makes
a lot of sense.
AUDIENCE: Of course that's
what we were thinking.
PROFESSOR: How about
let's not do that.
How about let's represent
it without layers?
So that's good.
You're getting closer
to the solution.
It is much better than
representing every time.
Write the number of
layers this time over 120,
it's a huge improvement.
Well, we can do it
without any-- we can do it
without any time
notion whatsoever.
Let's see, can I let
you think about it?
Oh, I can let you think
about it for 30 seconds.
So there's a key
insight here that--
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] but if
you figure how much time has
elapsed, based on
the items we have
and our starting state, right?
Because if we have
two hatcheries
and we started
with one hatchery,
we know that at least
nine seconds has elapsed.
PROFESSOR: Well, so I like the
first part of what you said,
the second part is
too complicated.
But we can know
what time we're at.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because it takes
a certain amount of time
to achieve everything,
each thing.
AUDIENCE: Are we assuming
that we take the shortest
path to get to each
state that we're at?
PROFESSOR: So we're
using the extra.
How does the extra work?
You have a queue,
a priority queue.
You extract a node, you
look at the neighbors.
When you extract
the node, do you
know the distance to that node?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain?
You ask?
PROFESSOR: I'm asking.
AUDIENCE: I know, but like
the node asks and says,
how far away are you?
PROFESSOR: So you need to keep
that in the priority queue.
So the extra--
the main invariant
is that once you
pull out the node,
you're not going to find any
shorter path to that node.
So you already know
the shortest path.
That how you sort the nodes
in the priority queue.
So when we're at
a configuration--
Say we're at some
configuration here,
two hatches, six drones,
and five Zerglings.
We already know that, say
we're at time 119 seconds.
If what I want to do next
is build another hatchery,
then I have to wait, what, six
drones, same thing as before.
I have to wait for
nine seconds, right?
So the edge would
look like this.
And then we're going to get
to three hatcheries, five
drones, five Zerglings.
This crosses a one, this crosses
a two-minute boundary, right?
So when I cross
this boundary, I'd
better have enough
Zerglings to do an attack.
Do I have enough
Zerglings to do an attack?
No.
So is this a valid move?
Is this the valid
edge in our graph?
It's not.
So when you're at a node,
you already know the time
that you need to
get to that node,
so when you generate
the neighbors,
you can check for
each edge to see
it crosses that 120 second game.
Now let's assume it does.
Let's see how this
works and this
is the last thing we're doing.
So suppose you have two
hatcheries, six drones,
and eight Zerglings.
And you're going to
build that same hatchery.
So you're going to go
past this 120 second mark.
What state are you
going to end up in?
How many hatcheries?
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How many drones.
AUDIENCE: Five.
PROFESSOR: How many Zerglings.
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So key elements, two
Zerglings, because this edge
crosses the 120-second
harassment boundary,
so you have to send
in six Zerglings
and you're going to lose them.
So we're taking advantage of
how the extra works to sort
of generate our
edges on the fly.
So we wouldn't be able
to regenerate this graph,
even if we wanted to have to.
We have to work with the
implicit representation
and, as we learn the
distances to the nodes,
the minimum distances,
we also learned the edges
that we have coming
out of those nodes.
AUDIENCE: So it's kinda of
like this graph that's growing
and we're like as it
gets to a certain point
we kill a bunch of paths
and then it keeps on going.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Doesn't this makes sense?
So the good news is
that this is like we're
training you to run
a 10-mile marathon,
so you can run 50
meters for the test.
Let's still try to
get it, because I
think it's a cool problem.